hey guys bring back bizdev Sunday you
gotta be up in the hall you rat rabbit
will get to cooperate both of our
ownership and average KPI detectors that
outdoors average
obviously in lieu of this episode you'll
see a bunch of b-roll you'll see some
stuff from the meetings and some deaths
uh actually we can film the second
meeting kind of pretty hardcore meeting
the second after we did the little film
that you just watched with the burger
thing but first let's look at this
burger I mean you did a nice job man
well thank you when I saw the picture
Mikey not going to make this look like
that kind of drilled it I'm pretty proud
to be honest it should I get resolved
and you cooked it a little bit further
through first time you cook it yeah well
I took these on Wednesday undercooked
the burger a little bit so I'm going to
try not to do that today take the first
bite of the Oh a little rib eye scent
does that send one of these that's my
parents and they loved it it's a ton of
food though they got three or four meals
out of it i'ma do my part right
everybody watching obviously when this
opportunity came up romantic to do this
Bronco burger
I was talking to the Vayner sports team
I was like hey let me clear some wine
with it so many of you out there when
you eat burgers barbeque season there's
a lot of great red wines to pair
Zinfandels not the white kind not the
pink eye does the Reds infidels but for
me what we're going to be preparing
salutary Amarone mainly from the Corvina
and run the media great Italian red wine
Matt you're just going to snippy snip
yeah cuz I'm not gonna get ourselves in
trouble here pleasure get ready it's a
field so you know I can't help at this
point time to make videos and not sneak
in a little bit of the thing that I'm
passionate about these days hustle hard
work things of that nature your career
so fascinating to me obviously when when
I got involved and we create Vater
sports you'd already been there do you
know what's the grot like tell me what
it feels like in your head right now to
go from a small town where you're
playing high school football that can't
even filled an entire team to to be
being in a situation where you're on a
practice squad right as a rookie and to
now literally you know those obviously
pro football focuses is a big benchmark
to being literally widely by a lot of
people consider the best senators
football or at least obviously when
people like a debate one one of them
how's that journey been like what do you
what do you associate that level of
success to from from those humble
beginnings to where you sit today I mean
it's exactly what you said it's really
it's the work ethic and would that come
from for you my parents instilled that
in me I mean yeah growing I grew up on a
cattle ranch and we were working from a
young age it was it was a well-known
that you know you're going to come out
of this child or the one one thing
you're going to know how to work and
just going through the story you know
hit a lot of had a lot of minor setbacks
and just I kept the attitude well if I
just keep working keep working hard it's
going to turn out in my favor and it did
after we did the little film that you
just watched with the burger thing we we
we did a really cool a really cool
financial business meeting real big
thinking format and and our players of
dinner sports and it kind of expired
made Iraq you inspired me to like bring
back a little bit of Sunday so
participant that Sunday Vayner sports so
many of you have local businesses
national businesses your marketing
managers a big brands the things we've
done with posts mates and Braxton Miller
but there's so much opportunity for us
to do incredible things with our
athletes at Vayner sports that are
breaking the mold with the content you
can get you get two for one you can get
the branding of our players and that and
that sponsorship that that endorsement
but then we at Vayner sports are
producing these assets these videos
these social media content that you can
use on your business's profile so if
you've got a small medium large size
business and you're thinking in the kind
of $10,000 to millions of dollars space
please email right here because em
Sunday for Vayner sports
looking to do some deals with our with
our 10 or so guys we've got a big
announcement of new guy on Monday
all-pro we're trying to bring the heat
and and so that's this week's because
that's Sunday and then and then actually
me feel like I want to bring them
business Sunday going to throw something
else I'm super passionate about my
podcast I want to explode it so if you
have a way to make my podcast greater
getting me an a-list celebrity as a
guest
getting distribution for my podcast if
you have a Facebook group that has a
million people in it my podcast is
something that I want to biz dev on and
so if there's something that you can do
in
turn what would you like just put that
in the email but don't waste your time
it needs to be meaningful my time is my
issue so if you're going to email about
that make it big have a great great week
ahead can last me good good content D
rocket I thought you added it extremely
well I'm proud of you I hope everybody's
hustling and we'll see soon
[Music]
I
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you